مع تكفيف في عمليات فحص المسافرين
بالمطارات في اجزاء من الساحل الشرقي
للولايات المتحده تزداد المخاوف ايجاء
متحول جديد من اومكروم يعرف باسم اكس بي
بي دوت 1 دوت فايف تقول منظمه الصحه ان
المتحوره موجود في 29 دوله وهو منتشر بشكل
خاص في الساحل الشرقي للولايات المتحده
وفي المملكه المتحده
الان قد يكون هناك المزيد حيث التسلسل
الجنيه غير متوفر على المستوى العالمي ومن
الصعب علينا تتبع كل هذه المتغيرات
الفرعيه من اوميكرام لذلك فهو جزء من
اوميكر الا انه اكثر المتغيرات الفرعيه
المكتشفه قابليه للانتقال وسبب في ذلك هو
الطفرات الموجوده داخله ما يسم ولهذا
الفيروس بالالتصاق بالخليليه والتكاثر
بسهوله ونحن قلقون بشان قدره على الانتشار
لا سيما في بعض البلدان الاوروبيه وفي
الولايات المتحده
وزياده عدد الاصابات بكرونا خلال عيد
الميلاد في المملكه المتحده حيث قدر مكتب
الاحصاءات الوطنيه ان نحو ثلاثه ملايين
شخص اصيب بالفيرس في الاسبوع المنتهي با
ال 28 من ديسمبر كانون الثاني وهو اعلى
مستوى المنذ الصيف
يبدو ان اكس بي دوت ون دوت فايف ينتقل
بشكل جيد جدا لذلك نعتقد ان الحرف ار
الخاصه به مرتفع جدا اي متوسط عدد الاشخاص
الذين ستنتقل لهم العدوى من شخص واحد مصاب
في ذلك يبدو في الولايات المتحده وكذلك في
المملكه المتحده ان النسبه الفيروسات من
هذه السلاله تزداد بشكل اسرع من جميع
المتغيرات الاخرى الموجوده حاليا
اه يقول العلماء ان لدى اكس بي بي دوت وان
دوت فايف طفره تعيد اليه القدره على
الارتباط بالخلايا مع الاستمرار في ايجاد
طرق جديده
لتجاوز اليات الجهاز المناعي في الجسم
وعلى الرغم من ان منظمه الصحه العالميه
تقول انه ليس اكثر خطوره من المتغيرات
الاخرى على هذا النحو فهل اللقاح فعال ضده
الطريقه التي يعمل بها اللقاح بشكل جيد
للغايه هي حمايه الناس من الامراض الشديده
ودخول المستشفى والوفاه وتستمر اللقاحات
في العمل بشكل جيد للغايه ضد جميع متغيرات
التي رايناها حتى الان لكن ما لا تفعله
اللقاحات هو منعه اصابه الناس بالعدوى
نتيجه لذلك يصاب المزيد من الناس وهذا هو
سبب قلق منظمه الصحه العالميه وخبراء
الصحه الاخرين